I'll tell about the libertarian why I
like the libertarian partly because
everybody agrees with half the things
the Libertarian Party says no reason I'm
a liberal if I'm a liberal I agree with
that half if you're a conservative you
agree with that half but if your
conservative you certainly don't agree
with Rand Paul on on the army and you
want to bring all the army men back home
I agree with that
I have Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today we're talking with radio and TV
legend Larry King who is currently
hosting politicking on Ora TV which airs
on Hulu the internet RT and other
outlets its own partly by Mexican
billionaire Carlos Slim as well as Larry
King himself and guests have ranged from
Christian personal finance guru Dave
Ramsey to former Clinton Secretary of
Labor Robert rice to socialist
independent senator Bernie Sanders to
young turks host sank Weger Larry you
were nominated last year for a news and
documentary at me for a program on head
trauma in the NFL what's the goal of
your show and why should people watch it
well first Nick I was shocked to be
nominated yeah because three years
before that I got a Lifetime Achievement
from the Emmy so I figure you get a
Lifetime Achievement your life's over
right so share it over time how would I
be nominated for an Emmy where I've
already it's like going into the
Baseball Hall of Fame and then playing
for the dots why why did so I was
thrilled I didn't know why did why
didn't you win because I we were the
only web show nominated you know and so
we lost a barbecue for Face the Nation
who's an old noise an old friend a good
guy oh come on say something bad about
Bob Schaffer nothing you could say in
Israel ever used to be the general
manager of the Houston Astros all right
okay so that's an insult that's one of
the few teams that hasn't made it into
the World Series correct many millions a
shoe a little bit and we'll get the
baseball better so what about your show
though what what is you know do you have
a particular goal I do two shows Larry
King now is a potpourri we have anywhere
from Broadway stars to political figures
to writers etcetera
like this Larry King Live on CNN and
politicking is all about politics and we
do that twice a week than we do Larry
King now three times a week and
politicking was the idea of our tea
which licenses our show so I don't work
for our tea the day license our show
when they paid Larry they pay or a TV
right for the right to carry and then
carry two a week and that we take with
no stipulations on us we've had more
critics of Putin yeah well okay so there
and when RT airs your show you have had
you've aired grievances against Putin
with an empty cut or without they don't
senator
okay would that matter if they were I
would not want to be licensed by them if
I did because I wouldn't want to work
for so talk about politics though you
know this is you know why why are you
doing specifically political political
why now our politics more interesting
than they used to be or well when I left
CNN we didn't do a lot of politics on
Larry King now one because we taped and
it played the next day and we couldn't
stay on top of an issue of air
politicking though is very close we will
tape it on Tuesday air at Wednesday and
I love politics and I miss the political
scene I lived in Washington for twenty
years now I live in LA I like politics
we talk about politics what do you like
about politics and yeah you've had it
you have every type of gala tosylates
though the country go around I mean you
could laugh at it but we need politics
we need politicians we I I'm not so sure
that the two-party system is the answer
where I would prefer one party and aa
cracy perhaps maybe Ernie you're going
at four in favor of world communism
right now know know what fascism okay
maybe a good no no I think John Kennedy
had the best idea to save politics a
kind King oh really you're in favor of a
kind Larry King or just I would I would
accept it in otherwise a monarchist a
monarchy that leaves us alone gives us
health care to me bet takes care of our
needs and at the same
time that delays up there do you need
health care I mean you obviously you've
written a number of best-selling books
about heart disease and whatnot but you
you're rich enough why should anybody in
America pay for anything for you nothing
they should not don't do but why should
we be 17th in the world in infant
mortality why should Huber deliver
faster medical services in the United
States well either they they beat their
citizens so they need it more but so you
would say that no as I if I could
perform the perfect it would be a one
payer system yes but and but you you
were saying basically it would be that
all the government would do is supply
health care and that let everything else
know as a health care provider an army
okay
defense defense not offense I wouldn't
start a war right okay control the
streets the civil ways courts police
absolutely I love a democracy mm-hmm I
wouldn't have a democracy where the
public votes on everything because that
that would be its in I would be anarchy
so what are the things what are what are
we doing now that the the gutter you
know the public should just be like you
have no so now we have what we have now
which is in my 81 years on the earth
I've never seen politics at a lower
esteem than they are right now we have a
house divided
and not just divided people don't like
each other when I agree I'm sorry I
didn't mean to make it that clear to you
but you know I'm giving off that vibe of
not liking you you don't like me I did
not I'm not saying that well you just
said people don't like each other
I slept in here that felt anti-semitism
through the bill it's not anti-semitism
it's because you're old okay Oh in its
ageism oh if I were only in China where
they Revere us
I can't believe I'm 81 by the way but no
the antipathy yeah anger
that exists and we had a country where
Goldwater and Kennedy were great friends
Orrin Hatch is Ted Kennedy's best friend
but do we want politicians to get I mean
it's one thing we've got we want to see
only the Republicans compromise and
unfortunately many in this country don't
unders
you have a stalemate but then what
happens I mean it seems to me that and
we're going through a budget season now
it's as likely to happen where instead
of compromise you get the worst kind of
Adam where Obama says hey let's take
over let's have the government run the
health care system which I find I have
real problems with but and then the
Republicans will say okay we'll finally
go along with that but then give us a
lot more money to start wars overseas
and that's you know the whole compromise
but it's going in the we're on direction
you can go half way a little so you have
Obamacare which is not one payer system
run right and now we have ten million
more people getting health care that we
haven't have all getting off and we
don't know how it's gonna slow down
matter so far I would say it I'm good
I'll take the back in history before you
were born nicht LSB okay I did a debate
in 1962 in Miami between Adonis
president of the AMA versus senator
Hubert Humphrey of Minnesota the debate
was about Medicare and the president the
AMA said Medicare will never work
doctors will not cooperate with it and
this is 1962 if we pass Medicare this
country will be the country will be
bankrupt by 1980 that was a debate this
bill would put the government smack into
your hospital defining services setting
standards establishing committees
calling for report deciding who gets in
and who gets out in 1938 the Republicans
all around voted against Social Security
called it 35 but yes hold it
socialism do you know anybody who would
turn away Social Security yes and
Medicare is bankrupting the country 1980
no but in the late
80s and this is something that Ronald
Reagan did one of the reasons we pay so
much of payroll taxes is to sit was to
save Social Security and Medicare and
Medicare is robbing systematically I
would argue and we'll move on from here
I would argue Medicare systematically
robs from younger poorer people to pay
for wealthier older people because
Medicare is mostly funded out of taxes
paid for by working people to people
like you who cover that oh but I would
I don't need Social Security not any men
when you say wealthy older people
relatively weaker how many what
percentage of older people would you
define as wealthy the people 65 and
older are among they have the most
assets they've they've said what would
you call wealth they have I think it's
it's fewer than 10% or below the poverty
line you're more likely to be below the
poverty line if you're under 30 than if
you're over 65 so that relatively
they're saying that most people overseas
well we don't need their Social Security
what I'm saying is saying 90% of people
overseas don't know yes they are above
the poverty line
you know that includes Social Security
what I'm saying is is that people who do
we should not be funding needs based
programs social welfare state programs
based on age I think we should do that
on need and most elderly people could
get by with reductions in Social
Security the system is bankrupt the
system returns negatively to people
under the age of about 55 I want i-i've
heard this and you could argue all day
long I wonder how this country exists
yeah how does it exist we've run up a
lot of debt do you what will you have to
pay off that eventually Clinton didn't
yeah actually he did run up the debt a
bit but that was very good but he had
trillion surplus yeah this is why you
get no you get no argument from me that
was better what we had under Bush was a
government that spent more and taxed
less even as revenues rose they Lyndon
Johnson worked by Joe Califano
published original 91 now republish
Lyndon Johnson fought a war and a Great
Society without increasing taxes
did increased taxes he and Lee he left
he left with a balanced budget because
he had a war tax which I think we should
always have war taxes for sure if we're
gonna fight a war we should pay for it
in the here and now now you know here
let me ask you say that we have fought
three unnecessary Wars Oh at least
probably money before yeah yeah no I
mean I think Korea Vietnam first Gulf
War Afghanistan in Iraq death I agree
was I said World War one maybe no well
talking about Joe Califano in that LBJ
administration he's a huge anti-drug
person a good friend I know I argue that
were you in favor of legalized drugs yes
I disagree with some good friend mary
oklahoma believe Mario Cuomo was a dear
friend he was a wonderful liberal
outstanding just a great guy that you
would define your politics generally as
you're kind of like a New Deal liberal
yeah I never bring it to the air though
yeah I never because I think my opinion
is irrelevant
the kind of show I did was to inform and
the guest counted what the guests
thought mattered I try to ask the best
questions I could listen to the answers
but what for example I never I never
learned anything when I was talking
that's the best way to describe my show
so my show was my opinion didn't count
where there was a movie or a political
election or I just thought I'd ask that
question you helped define you know for
many years of your career you helped to
find a long-form interview for radio and
TV do you feel that that's a lost art so
our it is so what what do we need to do
to recapture the pattern we have new
outlets where we could we can you within
what goes around comes around but the
youth today you talked about youth they
want it now I think they get in get out
hate children don't you you know you
were off also as you were helping to
develop or kind of you know make the
long-form interview a common form you
were often accused of doing softball
interview I never understood okay let's
talk about that you know people would
say look at your interviews with Marlon
Brando or OJ Simpson in the 90
and you know these were guys who were
going through all kinds of scandals and
you would never bring that up - so you
disagree with the idea that you're a
softcore never line it up with OJ
Simpson what scandal that I never I
brought up his wife beating yeah yeah
with Brando we brought up the Jewish
thing when he said that thing made the
statement on my show and Hollywood does
right hire Jews I don't mean did he mean
that in the most volatile a but I mean
what he had a feeling was that he was a
strong that before minorities the
American Indian I admired Brenda Jews
dark Anna's minorities or or not in
Hollywood well they're two percent of
America right maybe one and a half
percent
yeah I'd say they're a minority yeah
Hollywood they're not on our right but
they're they don't they don't always
nobody
what do you do when Marlon Brando goes
off on his tear about how the Jews are
what I did was give you what do you base
that on he'll say he said well they not
that they control it for Jews but they
don't let in Mexicans
how many Mexicans easy starring in
movies I say blaming that on Jews or is
that kind of the American culture so we
had that discussion and he took a lot of
hit for example someone told me we made
front page of the new york times more
than any talk show we were the only
radio talk show to win a Peabody I must
have done something right yeah and when
people accuse me of softball I never
understood it this often has give me the
question you know a lot of what I did my
interviewing style since I had long form
was I did a little lead-ups so for
example I'll get let's take an example
I'm gonna do Osama bin Laden the worst
first question you ask him if the Jews
control Hollywood no the worst your
funny Nick the worst first question to
ask Osama bin Laden is why did you bomb
two buildings in New York City
worst question one it makes a little
defensive to best first question
he's alive we're never gonna get that
question yeah hold on for a second this
is wonderful
are we in the air path of the I got the
best first question ask him why did you
leave one of the richest families in
Saudi Arabia to live in caves in
Afghanistan and Pakistan why now well I
don't know what his answer will be right
so I can't assume the next question but
there I have him telling me how he got
to be what he is what I'm trying to do
is walk in his shoes
by doing that we eventually will learn
what led to the man who ordered that
bombing because nobody evil thinks
they're evil Hitler didn't go in the
comas hair and say I am a terrible
person right so the way to get to what
motivates what they did is you don't go
in assuming they're a terrible person
you go in troubled wondering asking
questions
who was your who were your models as as
a media personality because when you
started in 57 so you've been at it for a
long time but who were you you know who
are the people who inspired was a kid I
loved more oh my heroes were the early
days of radio t this is like this is EBS
news guys I mean Muro Muro rockets Eric
severide he mud yeah those guys they
were tore that was a terrific a that was
when the news was CBS do you think we're
better off now that big networks we did
a weather at CNN or whether it's CBS
even Fox they're losing market share big
studios movie studios are scrambling
there's a million outlets such as aura
that are showing up on new things like
Hulu or just YouTube are we better off
that there are so many more outlets now
or should we are we missing anything by
having this concentrated you know few
outlets yes and no I I liked a lot of
the new I like the fact as long as when
they so one of the problems when this
more information is it becomes yet it
quick rather than get it right
and that's a danger I think the murrow's
got it right this is murder I spend most
of his time doing non-political so I'm
personally a person yeah you got to go
back to World War two and great
reporting and Morrow in London some of
the Gress foreign press reporting ever
was done by that CBS crew and the people
they he didn't have people on how they
looked had a lot of newspaper people
no person-to-person he did a lot of
movie stars and stuff other than that he
ran CBS News ran it very strongly and
independently they let him get away that
news department was not a profit maker
at sea but now news is a profit and it
was is that a problem
who should is the approach so what
should it be then it should be says I'm
independent and something that networks
carry out of a sense of public ability
sure used to be that way when the FCC
had remember equal time but yeah I love
nobody nobody benefited from equal time
LBJ LBJ used the FCC and licensing
requirements as a cudgel to keep the
people off the air the same thing that
Nixon did Franklin Roosevelt talked
about that do you really think do you
think that radio was better when the FCC
regulated things very tightly I worked
in it yeah I worked in it oh well maybe
it was better for you oh no no it wasn't
better for me I was a regular for
example when I did my show if we gave
you 15 minutes and we had to give the
other mayor candidate 15 what is wrong
with that do we have a lack of mayoral
candidates getting equal time today oh
sure really of course you know to buy
the time don't you think I mean I will
let me ask you from a do you think you
think that every candidate gets equal to
know what I did when I was started yeah
I know but what I'm saying is is that we
people have access to media in ways that
they didn't before and I know that you
know an outfit like reason of you know a
small magazine an intellectual magazine
now has a website that pulls four
million views of visits a month a
million views on YouTube none of this
was happening on
the old days of equal time where things
were regulated I'm worried about net
neutrality the idea that the FCC the
same agency that spent a decade let you
know litigating and Janet Jackson's
nipple at the Super Bowl they're gonna
be in charge of the internet I'm worried
about that kind of stuff
shouldn't you be I don't die away so
against net neutrality what's wrong I
because I don't want the government
dictating terms of that day internet how
we get on Iran see I don't have a I
don't have a Mexican billionaire in my
back pocket throw out there that's cute
so talk about under so you
I like regulation you uh you that you
let it run them up in the inmates are
running the asylum for example you
reduce regulations so now one guy could
own six regular sessions in the same
market that's absurd it does it doesn't
serve the public but it does not serve
doesn't matter when most people get
their you know get radio or they can
listen to podcasts they can do anything
they want we can but other major sources
of information but they're declining
right because they di play any good I
favored the FCC's requirement of equal
time it served as well and I think it
produced better candidates really yeah
well there you may have some goo
standing because certainly the
candidates were getting in my lifetime
have not been particularly legal but you
may have an article candidates if you
never get to hear from yeah well then
certainly well you were saying you don't
like the two-party system would you like
to see more parties have access to the
airwaves sure yeah what's wrong with
more party nothing I would the more the
merrier
I favor the Liberty ok well I've every
every campaign I have ever covered
always had the libertarian K oh you
always have a lot of third party
candidates that's correct Louis and I
moderated the third party debate to
couple years ago what uh what what if
which of the third parties wins your
heart if you could come out and I tell
you about the libertarian why I like the
libertarian partly because everybody
agrees with half the things the
libertarian party says there is I'm a
liberal if I'm a liberal I agree with
that half if your conservative you agree
with that half but if your conservative
you certainly don't agree with rent
on on the army and you want to bring
bolli army men back home I agree with
that see that I agree yeah and you like
gay marriage all right absolutely okay
so why can't a libertarian ever win you
know half the votes yes I don't agree I
like to regulate unregulated businesses
that could in other words you you have
who is the greatest libertarian in the
history of American politics
depending on how that's one of my vessel
Larry King yeah well you know besides
Osama bin Laden in American policy I
would say hey son well well here you
know what do you notice that a
little-known great checker player really
Osama bin Laden two tops I thought you
were gonna say very against he wanted to
raise the minimum wage to $15 I one of
the things we celebrate a lot at reason
is the ways in which Jimmy Carter for
instance who's nobody idea of a
libertarian but he deregulated the
trucking industry deregulated air at the
airline industry freight rail and that
led to he deregulated more industries
than Ronald Reagan ever did Ronald
Reagan was not a conservative is not a
libertarian for sure Richard Nixon was
was a liberal yep I said so who do you
think is the deregulation of the
airlines absolutely only oh no okay well
tell tell tell me let's just check air
fares today yeah let's check routes
today yes okay how we cut it all down so
we more like a problem and you can't get
awfully why do so many more wait so
you're saying planes are crowded because
people can afford them and they're going
for place there crowd Eagle are and why
crowded because this airline decides we
control to Des Moines oh but this is so
much less than under regulation we fly
10 flights a day we'll fly five then
we'll cram them all in so we would fly
well not the other airline good aura TV
say why should we you know we're gonna
run fifty programs that nobody watches
or we're gonna run five that actually
get an audience well I know but every
study shows airlines are safer more
people fly you would burn
yes you would like just anything goes
right yes okay if airlines when they
don't have recourse to the government to
regulate the routes and their money and
their profits they make sure that they
don't fall out of the sky and they
actually make sure that they respond to
consumer need more and sit disagree with
that gotta give how many airlines are
out of business and say about with tons
but there are constantly going in and
out but the important thing is planes
keep flying so the chairs so you're you
either you care about I don't want us I
got an idea maybe you would favor this
one airline out are you see I'd like
many airlines so you'd like Aeroflot
right you're you're sad that you know
Aeroflot I don't like our flight at all
but they have a great flight from LA to
Moscow have a 777 was once a day to
mosque for like one person right and
it's a you you fly first-class right yes
yeah okay so trust me you don't you have
no idea what's going on in the back of
the fly on the back oh absolutely
absolutely and I'm glad that I catch the
question I'm glad that is your question
makes LSB what goes on back there
you don't want to know that sex goes out
that oh it's it's plane you look like
lop it it's a mile-high club you know
what anything that's peaceful as long as
everybody's volunteer okay okay so if
I'm walking down the plane and a couple
or a homosexual couple or a heterosexual
yeah I'll having sex you know I don't
know if it's a sexual preference Larry I
just erased that's right and the rest of
their people are just reading papers
it's okay it depends if you're told
ahead of time you know one of the your
ticket is either gonna be more or less
because you're on a plane where
spontaneous sexual activity might be
breaking out you know if you were now
again you're beyond money you're richer
than most I'm the only person richer
than you is you're Mexican billionaire
friend Carlos Slim it was fun working on
our to he's was 77 billion a lot of Dow
that's a lot of potatoes you think I am
NOT a good interviewer huh no you're
you're telling me things about myself
that I haven't even admitted to Ameri
you have skirted yes a question I don't
which question most famous livid yeah no
I I the most famous low return you never
answered it no in terms of politics yeah
yeah I don't know I would not say that
there's any
I like Gary Johnson the governor of New
Mexico like Gary alive you gotta know he
hasn't other than helping New Mexico be
less of a basket case
he and being a great ambassador for
libertarianism I don't know that he's
great so I I don't have a Gary Johnson
ya lot yeah we've had him on the lodge a
good guy yeah and we were half of what
he says yeah
all right there you go so who do you
think is the greatest libertarian and
Larry while you're pondering this not
quite why did you why did you bomb those
buildings in New York why did you order
that the bombing of those buildings you
see I was drawing you out your cute Nick
yeah I tell you what Nick let's listen
all listen to Nicolas Lee I've got an
idea
no police come on Nick don't name Feliz
government handle your own I run your
own block do you want you don't like the
bright robber killable let's do the
Nancy Grace approach to the courtroom
when charge you will appear in court on
the date specified and you will be
shocked no trial
save a lot of money so you're in favor
of Ferguson style policing because that
works out so well no I'm all right are
you saying that the police no II think
one day my leave Larry my ability of the
Ferguson style yeah the blacks would
control all the neighborhoods all right
so that sounds pretty libertarian right
be police or or they don't know local
name whatever you want okay you can wear
whatever uniform you all right if you if
you want that's a libertarian who are
just constantly bringing about this sex
and nudity you're 81 years old you are
on your eighth marriage right across
seven women eight marriages come on okay
bye oh you know just you you must be
doing something right let me ask you
this
sanely it's showing it is it's bleeding
I'm Carrie are you still into cryonics
you talked yes that I would like to be
okay I put it on putting it in my will
I'll tell you why I don't believe here
I'm an atheist yep most most I guess
libertarian should be atheist many are
to believe in something above you don't
believe in anything benefit sometimes
but you know I believe
in all sorts of things but yes okay so
you don't believe it in afterlife so you
might be around I want to be around to
pick up the pieces
it's an old song but yes I want to be
around and the only possible guarantee
is cryonics where they inject you with a
compound that will keep you in a put you
in a tube and if they cure the disease
they wake you so it and you're gonna be
like Ted well you'll be able to talk to
they don't they don't okay that's a miss
miss a just son I was just done dr. oz
and he shortened exactly how they do it
you take the body immediately they put
an injection in to keep the shaken to
keep the blood you're not betting on dr.
oz how's your afterlife physician are
you I'll take anybody okay so when you
wake well you don't like dr. oz dr. oz
there's a lot of ethical questions about
his you know kind of state the
government shouldn't control it no I
don't think people should be free to
critique it or analyze or dollar for an
independent evaluation other than the
people who wake you up from cryonics who
would be on your first talk show panel
after a year it was and who's around
yeah but I'll ask questions I'll meet
new people in the plant Williams had and
maybe a couple of people who who are
just from the current Walt Disney best
interview ever Sinatra Sandy Koufax or
Danny Kaye Sinatra Koufax is not verbal
enough he's good diabetes is Sandy
Koufax gang no are you kidding okay
there's a long-standing rumor about him
okay yeah that's a joke it does it
matters heavily does it matter to your
audience he's a great pitcher a great
actually a great character throughout
after his baseball career please know
about he's very quiet and he's but yeah
but he's he's a good guy he's alright
son nice you know he's always done right
by people very little done with you yeah
well he's perfect you can work on that
it doesn't matter to you as a person you
know I mean you're 81 you're in your
what seventh or seventh decade and
Media something like 50 60 80 90 mm do
you ever feel like you're you're getting
out of touch with what what your main
audience wants you know what keeps me
going is on aura we do a lot of hip-hop
stars and stuff um who's your favorite
rapper lately I was who was the guy I
had on not ice-t Ice Cube Ice Cube I
like ice cube but who was the guy we had
on Bow Wow he's no longer little Bow Wow
don't make the mistake of calling him
little bow you know all about this I
have a little bit about it but who is
who is the who is the gutter run
greatest interview ever name it besides
this one of course Sinatra all right
well thank you so much you make the
Larry King Irish hosting politicking on
aura TV which airs on Hulu all over the
internet RT and other places Larry came
on so much it's so nice to be among
reasonable people